so you made a thesis film uh entitled
who framed the movie critic is that
right and we were talking earlier about
how in france a movie critic has so much
power
how do you feel movie critics should be
regarded and do you submit your films
to be critiqued
i
enjoy a lot of critics and
and i
um
i want to have more and more feedbacks
about what i do so of course i'm i'm
not the kind of guy who's going to say
you don't know nothing so don't talk
about my movie i i love having the most
feedback i can about my movies
and
i think that what a lot of
critics
would need to have is
more knowledge of how you make a movie i
mean how we make a movie and it's i mean
i think that a lot of critics have these
um
these theories they have this knowledge
this great knowledge about movies like
from
uh the expressionist uh german cinema
too uh nowadays blockbusters they have
this great knowledge but i think that a
lot of them
lack
um a sense of craft of filmmaking i
think and that's what struck me when i
made the jump from
creating myself to
a director
is that
not a lot of people know the craft of
filmmaking and i think that
i don't consider myself as an artist and
i don't consider
filmmaker
as artists but but more as
craft men
and i think that i mean it's like it's
like carpenters i mean it's like it's
it's something you just go with your
hands and your bare hands and just work
on a set it's very physical it's i think
that's why it's more of a craft
and i think that a lot of critics
don't have
this knowledge of the craft of
filmmaking so you studied to be
a film critic or that was your hopes
yeah exactly i studied to be from critic
i've been a film critic for a while in
france
and i
it
i realized that
it was a conservative choice for me to
do that and uh i really wanted to be
a director
forever to make my movies and not only
talk about
other people's movies so i made a jump
and i decided no you have to make movies
and tell the stories your way
where did you study in france so yeah in
france i studied a movie critique in la
soberano to be i studied journalism at
la sargon and with this idea of me uh
wanting to be a film critic
so yeah it was a lesser one do you
remember the day or a few incidents when
you said you know what this isn't for me
well
i have a lot of moments like that where
i said to myself it's not for me
i
uh i was
a lot younger and maybe a bit uh
now when i look back maybe a bit
back in the days uh obnoxious about what
i wanted to do was like i wanted to make
movies and and i was didn't make a clear
choice i said i wanted to make
uh movies and artistical stuff but i was
still
learning to be a critic so i was in in
um
at the crossroads of
the two of them and i didn't make a
clear choice so i cannot say that
every single time i was going to make an
interview to make a report and a movie
uh interview filmmakers actors all that
stuff i
every single time i was like i want to
be on the other side and i want to tell
my stories because that's what i want to
do
and so yeah pretty much all the time
then to answer your question i've been
thinking about that